en el vídeo anterior aprendimos que si
tenemos dos triángulos que tienen todos
los lados correspondientes en ambos
triángulos iguales entonces por lado
lado a lado tendremos congruencia
congruencia
congruencia y también mencionamos algo
de axiomas y postulados pero quiero ser
muy claro aquí
a veces se escuchan esto referido como
teorema
o postulado
postulado o acción acción
así que vamos a diferenciar un poco su
significado
estos dos postulados y axioma se asumen
que son cierto mientras que el teorema
es lo que probamos usando cosas más
básicas como axiomas o postulados en
matemáticas tenemos ciertos postulados
núcleo o postulados básicos tenemos
estos elementos postulados axiomas
básicos
axioma
axiomas
o postulados
postulados
que son cosas obvias que son cosas que
son ciertas y no requieren de pruebas
y usando estos demostramos teoremas con
base en estos axiomas a partir de ellos
vamos generando teoremas por ejemplo
este sale de aquí
de este otro acción más sale este
teorema a lo mejor de estos dos al
unirlos sale otro teorema a lo mejor
aquí sale otro teorema que al unirlo con
éste nos da un teorema demás y así
sucesivamente creo que con esto pueden
darse una idea con esto tratamos de
construir nuestro conocimiento
matemático alrededor de estos postulados
axiomas básicos en nuestras clases de
introducción a la geometría hemos
probado de manera rigurosa este elemento
del lado lado a lado por eso ya lo
podemos dar por sentado como axioma o
postulado
donde esto es para que conozcan la
diferencia entre estas palabras teorema
y postulado y acción y también para que
no se confundan esto de aquí ya está
comprobado aunque en muchos libros se lo
encuentran como el teorema al lado lado
al lado aunque no necesariamente lo
hayan probado rigurosamente así que es
más un axioma un postulado
aclarado esto y a partir de ahora vamos
a asumir que lado lado un lado es algo
dado y les quiero mostrar que podemos
hacer cosas útiles con esto digamos que
tenemos un círculo que voy a dibujar
a partir de
en este punto voy a dibujar un círculo
algo así lo más proporcionado que se
pueda
y este círculo tiene su centro en el
punto y digamos que tenemos una cuerda
qué va
de este punto a este punto de la
circunferencia esta cuerda no es un
diámetro y también digamos que tenemos
un radio que parte del centro del
círculo a este punto de la
circunferencia de manera que be secta o
divide en dos partes iguales esta cuerda
así que este segmento de acá será igual
que el segmento de aquí y vamos a
etiquetar esto vamos a ponerle etiquetas
a estos vértices vamos a llamar
bueno deja quedamos que estés a este
punto de aquí va a ser mejor este de
arriba este de que iba a ser de este
punto de acabarse y este otro punto de
acá va a ser de
lo que quiero probar ahora
lo que quiero probar
quiero probar
el segmento de línea ave este segmento
de ave es perpendicular al segmento de
líneas cede a la cuerda que pasa por acá
es decir que ave forma un ángulo recto
concede y voy a probarlo usando el
postulado lado lado lado para usar esto
voy a necesitar algunos triángulos y
aunque ahora no los tengo los puedo
construir usando cosas que ya conozco
por ejemplo puede agregar un radio que
va de aã de un radio aquí y puedo
agregar de hecho yo creo que lo voy a
hacer en otro color para que pueda
notarse mejor un radio que va de aã de y
voy a agregar otro radio que va del
centro a c d
hace aquí está
sabemos que ambas líneas de hace y de
ave tienen la misma longitud que es el
radio del círculo así que estas líneas
de acá me den lo mismo
podemos decir que hace es congruente con
la de del planteamiento del problema
sabemos que esta mitad de la cuerda es
igual a esta otra mitad y a este punto
intermedio lo vamos a llamar
por lo que el segmento c es igual al
segmento ed también sabemos que ambos
triángulos este es uno de los triángulos
este es uno de los triángulos y el otro
triángulo este de acá
que estoy poniendo en morado
comparten el lado a este lado de aquí
es igual a sí mismo es igual a él así
que este segmento de aquí ese segmento
de aquí es igual a sí mismo y estos son
triángulos adyacentes así que tenemos
una situación en la que tenemos dos
triángulos que tienen lados
correspondientes iguales así que por el
postulado
por lado lado lado
nos implica que el triángulo
a ese este triángulo
es congruente es congruente con el
triángulo
con este triángulo de aquí de la derecha
para que les quede más claro este lado
de acá es congruente con este lado de
acá este lado de acá también tiene el
mismo tamaño es congruente con este lado
de acá y este que sea decente pues es
igual para ambos triángulos
como nos ayudan esto con lo que queremos
probar
pues lo general es que una vez que
probamos que estos dos triángulos son
congruentes podemos decir que los
ángulos también son congruentes la
medida del ángulo que lo voy a poner en
amarillo para que resalte la medida de
mi ángulo c&a este ángulo de aquí va a
ser igual congruente con la medida del
ángulo d
este ángulo de acá
lo escribo la medida del ángulo
a es igual a la medida del ángulo d
ah
y esto es útil porque hablo observa el
diagrama vemos que son ángulos
suplementarios
estos ángulos son adyacentes y esos
extremos
forman un ángulo ya no un ángulo de 180
grados son suplementarios y equivalentes
así que mi medida del ángulo mi medida
del ángulo c
a más la medida del ángulo de a es igual
a 180 grados no son equivalentes puedo
reemplazar puedo escribir la medida del
ángulo c&a
la medida del ángulo se halla que son
equivalentes el de ella y el cea
estos van a ser igual a 180 grados que
es lo mismo que dos veces por la medida
del ángulo c&a
igual a 180 grados por lo tanto la
medida 180 grados
la medida del ángulo se a
es igual a 180 grados
/ 2 igual a 90 grados
y que esto también es igual a la medida
del ángulo de a
por lo que hemos probado que este ángulo
es de 90 grados
este también es de 90 grados son ángulos
rectos por lo que ave es perpendicular a
cd